大家好，欢迎各位来到课堂。我叫戴维·布朗。这是一堂语法课。你好。欢迎。欢迎来到课堂。诺玛 (Nuòmǎ)，欢迎。你好。谢谢。你怎么样？我很好。你呢？我非常好。谢谢。
诺玛，你周末过得好吗？是的，我和家人度过了一个愉快的周末*。
太好了。非常棒。你和你儿子一起度过时光了吧，对吗？他叫何塞·巴勃罗 (Hésè Bābóluó)？是的。他总是想*和我玩。所以我在家除了和他玩，什么也做不了。
好的，听起来确实是个不错的周末。诺玛，在这节课上，我们将讨论周末，并且会讨论规则动词和不规则动词，以及这两者之间的区别。
以及如何运用发音和顺序副词来描述我们的周末。让我们读一下这里的学习目标。你能看清屏幕吗？是的，我能看清。
好的，太好了。让我们从朗读这里开始。你能为我读一下这行吗？谈论过去。你会看到所有过去式动词，如 washed, went, ate。
用来描述已完成的事件。好的。下一个呢？然后是下一个顺序。组织你的故事。使用特定的词语。First, then, next. After that, finally，按正确的顺序讲述事情。
发音清晰，练习正确发出 -ed 动词结尾的音。好的。然后写你的故事。写一个三到五句话的短段落，描述一个个人过去的事件。
好的，太好了。这些就是我们今天课程的目标。
我们知道有过去时、现在时和将来时。我们有不同的动词变位形式，许多学生在一般过去时态上遇到相当大的困难，原因有二：第一，以 ED 结尾的动词有不同的发音方式。
另外，因为有太多不规则的过去式动词，可能超过200个不规则过去式动词需要我们记忆。
所以我们看到基本的动词结构基本上是动词原形加 ed。那就是一般过去时。而且大多数情况下都适用。所以我们只需在词尾加上 ed。例如，我们有 finish，在过去式中是 finished。
动词原形，然后是其余部分。这里有一个例子。你能为我读一下这个例子吗？
现在时，watch TV，过去式，yesterday, I watched* a movie.
好的。很好。我们将多练习一些发音。对于母语是西班牙语的人来说，发出 watched 中 ch 的音可能有点困难。
但你会掌握的。别担心。
所以我们也会看到像这样的例子。They play soccer. 然后过去式变成 They played soccer. 你可以听到这个词有不同的发音。
第一个是 /t/ 音，第二个是 /d/ 音。然后这里有另一个例子。你能为我读一下这个吗？
She cooks dinner 过去式 she chicken dinner last night. (chicken -> cooked)
很好。所以基本的拼写规则是我们需要在动词末尾加上 ed。
有些时候我们需要把 y 改成 i 再加 ed。例如，study 在过去式中变成 studied，或者 cry，
在过去式中变成 cried，加上 ied。
但大多数时候，你只需在动词末尾加上 -ed 就可以把它变成过去式。
好的。我们继续。在我们继续之前，你有什么问题要问我吗？
不，我只是想说，正如您提到的，这很难。这是我开始学习英语时最难的部分之一，就是过去时态，因为那个发音部分。
但我们努力练习再练习。
我理解。当我们尝试做困难的事情时，感到有点紧张是正常的。
到目前为止，你做得真的非常非常好，非常出色。所以别担心，诺玛。
好的。所以一个有挑战性的事情，正如你提到的，是了解所有这些规则动词。
所以我们需要记住它们。记忆这些不同的动词确实没有捷径。
当然，我们需要在语境中使用它们，但我们真的需要记住所有这些不规则的过去式动词。
我们这里有一些例子。go 在过去式中是 went... eat 在过去式中是 ate。
have 在过去式中是 had* see 在过去式中是 saw，drink 在过去式中是 drank，make 在过去式中是 made。
发音很好。buy 的过去式是什么？Bought。
哦，好的。这个呢？
wake up 的过去式是 woke up。
好的。然后我们需要记住动词 to be 的这些变位形式。
所以我们不仅有规则动词，有时它们在过去式变位中看起来完全不同。
所以我们有 be，然后是 was 或 were 作为 to be 的过去式。
好的。这些只是一小部分不规则动词的例子。
我真的建议你有时间的时候，试着找一些这些不规则动词的列表并使用它们。
每当你谈论过去时，都要想到它们。确保你正确地进行了动词变位。
让我们测试几个。我想我们可以继续了，因为你做得非常好。
go 在过去式中是 went，have 在过去式中是 had，drink 在过去式中是 drank。
很好。buy 的过去式是…… Bought?
哇。好的。你的发音真的进步了很多。我印象非常深刻。
谢谢。
好的。所以我们有三种不同的方式来发这些以 -ed 结尾的动词的音。
我们以前也做过一些这方面的隐含练习，但我认为理解这些规则中的一些也非常有用。
当我们发以 -ed 结尾的动词的音时，我们会发出三种不同的声音。
一种是用你的牙齿发出的 /t/ 音。
另一种是 /t/ 音，它在牙齿后面，就在那个叫做齿龈缘 (chǐyínyuán) 的地方。
我们在那里发 d-d 的音。然后我们有 id 的音。
所以它从这个浊音开始，元音就是从这里来的。
然后它以你口腔顶部的 dip 音结束。
所以我们有 dip 和 id，这取决于最后的辅音。
所以例如 watch 的最后一个辅音是 ch，重复，重复，重复。
就是这样。非常好。好的。所以我们有 watched? 这个非常难。
Watched? Watched? Watched? Watched? 非常好。
很棒。然后 look 变成。Looked。
Looks 非常好。Stop 是。Stopped。对。所以我们没有以 a /t/ 结尾的音从这里开始。
然后我们有 d 音。记住在口腔顶部。
所以我们有 play，过去式变成，记住 /d/。跟我读。
非常好。Played. Played.
很好。这个呢？Opened.
很棒。这个呢？
Lived. 哇。完美。太棒了。
所以你可以记住这些规则。
经过一段时间的练习和长时间的聆听，你就能学会它们。
但是如果你记住，如果它以 L, B, V, G, M, R, Z, 或 J 开头，或者更确切地说，如果最后一个辅音是这些，
那么结尾就会发出那个 /d/ 音。
需要记住的最重要的规则是，当最后一个辅音是 "t" 或 "d" 时，
那么我们要在结尾发 -id 的音。
所以我们有 wanted，最后一个辅音是 "t"。
wanted，是 wanted。need 的最后一个辅音是什么？Needed。
所以是 D。最后一个辅音是 D。所以是 needed 和 decided。
Decided。完美。好的。所以我们在结尾加上了那个 id 音的额外音节。
我想我们可以继续了。你感觉怎么样？
这对你来说容易吗，还是有点太难了，或者你怎么看？
我觉得你做得很好。
不，我感觉很自在。